[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic comment représenter visuellement la
relativité générale
cette vidéo a pour but de lister les
différentes représentations de la
théorie et d'en proposer une nouvelle
que je n'ai pour l'instant rencontrée
nulle part alors qu'elle possède un
grand nombre de qualités
l'idée derrière cette représentation est
d'exploiter au maximum le format vidéo
et en particulier sa dimension
temporelle afin de restituer fidèlement
ce que nous disent les mathématiques de
la théorie au collège puis au lycée on
apprend que la chute des corps peut être
modélisée par une force c'est la force
de gravité le poids cette force permet
de décrire le mouvement des objets en
disant qu'ils sont attirés les uns par
les autres et en particulier par les
astres massif comme la terre mais cette
description n'est qu'une approximation
et ne fonctionne pas dans certains cas
de forte gravité comme la trajectoire de
mercure autour du soleil
c'est en 1915 qu'albert einstein va
proposer une nouvelle théorie un modèle
mathématique rigoureux qui permet de
décrire cette fois-ci de façon plus
exact la chute des corps pour einstein
il n'est plus question d'une force qui
agirait à distance c'est le tissu de
l'univers lui-même l'espace temps qui va
se déformer et entraîner les objets dans
leur chute
pour pouvoir expliquer cette théorie
complexe au grand public
il est nécessaire de concevoir des
visualisations qui la rendent plus
abordable la représentation qu'on en
fait le plus souvent
d'une grande toile élastique sur
laquelle serait posé les astres massif
en déformant la toile sous leur poids
les astres entraîne le mouvement des
autres corps dans leur direction
un peu comme une bille dans un bol a
priori cette visualisation présente deux
avantages conséquents
elle est très simple et intuitive et
elle permet de bien comprendre que les
corses attire de façon indirecte par le
biais d'un intermédiaire sous jacent
l'espace temps dont ils influencent la
géométrie
cela dit bien qu'elle soit extrêmement
répandu cette façon d'imagés la
relativité générale présente un grand
nombre de problèmes qui la rendent peu
rigoureuse dans cette vidéo nous allons
tenter d'améliorer cette image en lui
apportant quatre modifications majeures
pour commencer l'image de la toile
élastique semble indiquer que les astres
sont posés sur l'espace temps comme des
billes
alors que dans la réalité l'espace temps
est le tissu de l'univers qui les
englobe les contient une première
amélioration que l'on peut apporter
serait donc de représenter les objets à
plat sur la surface de sorte que l'on
comprenne bien qu'il ne sont pas
extérieur mais contenue à l'intérieur de
l'espace temps
[Musique]
ensuite l'un des plus gros problème de
cette représentation est qu elle
explique en quelque sorte la gravité par
la gravité à la question pourquoi là
pomme tombe sur terre cette
visualisation semble répondre que c'est
parce que la pomme est attiré vers le
bas ce qui la force à tomber le long du
creux dans la toile pour expliquer la
gravité dans l'espace temps il n'est pas
acceptable de faire appel à une gravité
à l'extérieur de l'espace temps il va
donc falloir trouver un meilleur
argument en l'occurrence il est plus
rigoureux de dire que si les objets
suivent le renfoncement créé par la
terre c'est parce qu'ils se déplacent en
ligne droite et dans une géométrie
courbet quand ils tombent les objets
avance tout droit mais la courbure de
l'espace temps nous donne l'impression
que ces trajectoires sont déviés pour
comprendre
on peut par exemple imaginer la surface
d'une sphère sur laquelle deux fourmis
partirait en direction du pôle nord au
départ les deux trajectoires sont
parallèles et on pourrait penser qu'en
avançant tout droit les deux lignes
parallèles ne se croiseront jamais
pourtant les deux fourmis finissent par
se rencontrer au pôle nord
ceci est possible grâce à la géométrie
courbet de la sphère sur laquelle deux
lignes droites parallèles ont tendance à
se rapprocher dans l'espace temps le
phénomène est similaire et les objets
semble s'attirer alors qu'ils suivent
simplement la courbure en ligne droite
[Musique]
troisièmement cette image d' un
renfoncement dans la toile est trompeuse
en effet on pourrait être amené à penser
que si l'espace tente se courber c'est
grâce à l'existence d'une dimension
supérieure
ici par exemple la toile à deux
dimensions semble se courber dans une
troisième dimension
en réalité ce n'est pas le cas et les
mathématiques de la relativité ne
nécessite aucune dimension supérieure
pour que l'univers puisse courbet il est
donc préférable de ne pas représenter la
toile vue de côté mais plutôt du dessus
avec une grille qui donne l'idée de la
déformation au passage ceci nous permet
également de rétablir les trois
dimensions des espaces dans lesquels
nous vivons
[Musique]
enfin le problème le plus important de
cette représentation est le fait que
notre diagramme fait complètement
abstraction de la dimension temporelle
l'espace temps est un objet à quatre
dimensions trois dimensions des spas ce
que l'on a déjà représenté mais
également une dimension de temps qui
peut elle aussi se courber et se déforme
et représenter fidèlement une géométrie
d'espace-temps à quatre dimensions est
strictement impossible
il va donc falloir trouver une astuce
une première idée serait d'ajouter des
petites horloges à notre diagramme en
chaque point de la grid espace de cette
façon là grid espace devient une grille
d'espace-temps et on comprend que le
temps peut s'écouler de façon différente
en fonction de l'endroit où l'on se
situe
cela dit ajouter des horloges à notre
diagramme ne nous donne pas beaucoup
plus d'intuition
et en particulier on ne comprend
toujours pas vraiment ce qui pousse les
objets à tomber si on lâche une pomme
par exemple pourquoi là pomme se
met-elle en mouvement vers la terre pour
comprendre il est nécessaire de
supprimer une dimension des espaces pour
pouvoir représenter la dimension
temporelle
en effet c'est bien la composante
temporelle de la courbure qui permet
d'expliquer la gravité dans un tel
diagramme on comprend que la pomme est
en fait constamment en mouvement
même quand elle est immobile au départ
de sa chute
la pomme se déplace toujours dans le
temps elle avance vers le futur lorsque
la pomme ne subit aucune force la
courbure de l'espace-temps va
progressivement faire tourner sa
trajectoire entre une vitesse temporel
vers le futur et une vitesse spatiale
diriger vers le sol la pomme se déplace
en ligne droite mais la courbure de
l'espace-temps fait tourner et
l'orientation de cette ligne droite
entre une direction temporel et une
direction spatiale diriger vers le bas
[Musique]
on comprend que si la pomme tombe vers
le sol c'est parce qu'elle avait dès le
départ une vitesse temporel diriger vers
le futur la courbure de l'espace-temps
générés par la terre n'a fait que
convertir cette vitesse temporel en une
vitesse spatiale
[Musique]
mais en tant qu'êtres humains nous ne
percevons pas la vitesse temporelle des
objets quand une pomme est lâché dans
l'espace elle nous semble immobile on ne
perçoit pas le fait qu'elle possède une
vitesse dans le temps de notre point de
vue nous n'avons accès qu'à des tranches
successives de l'espace temps nous
voyons évoluer l'espace instant après
instant et ce diagramme où les objets
forme des tubes au cours du temps des
lignes d'univers n'est pas forcément
très intuitif notre dernière étape va
donc être de prendre des tranches
successives de ce diagramme de le
découper instant par instant de sorte à
former une animation qui inclut le
caractère temporel la courbure de
l'espace temps qui fait plonger les
lignes droites dans la terre devient un
mouvement de contraction de l'espace au
cours du temps le rythme de cette
contraction est constant et perpétuelle
car la courbure de l'espace-temps qui ne
dépend que de la masse de la terre ne
varie pas au cours du temps attention il
est très important de comprendre que ce
n'est pas la géométrie qui se contracte
ce sont les lignes droites qui se
rapproche à cause de la courbure et
donne l'impression de se contracter
le phénomène est similaire à la surface
d'une sphère la courbure y est constante
mais les lignes droites semble
perpétuellement se rapprocher
[Musique]
c'est cette représentation qui me paraît
personnellement la plus appropriée pour
visualiser la relativité générale la
terre car elle est très massive des
formes l'espace-temps lui imprimant une
courbure de notre point de vue la
courbure de l'espace temps apparaît
comme une contraction perpétuelle de
l'espace au cours du temps en termes
techniques ont dit que le volume
renfermé parler géodésique diminué au
cours du temps à cause de la courbure
cette grille des espaces qui se
contracte représente ce qu'on appelle
les référentiels inertielle en chute
libre à l'intérieur de cette grille un
objet qui ne subit aucune force va
conserver son mouvement et sa vitesse
ainsi si on lâche la pomme immobile
comme elle ne subit aucune force
elle va rester immobile par rapport la
grille mais comme la grille se contracte
la baume va tomber au cours du temps
avec cette façon de représenter la
relativité il est également facile de
voir que le sol de la planète accélère
constamment vers le haut car il s'oppose
de façon perpétuelle au mouvement
naturel de la grille enfin si on lance
un objet sur le côté avec une vitesse
initiale à chaque instant l'objet ne
subit aucune force et va donc continuer
en ligne droite dans la grille mais
comme la grille se contracte l'objet est
perpétuellement ramener vers le sol et
c'est de cette façon que la lune orbite
autour de la terre et que la terre en
orbite autour du soleil
[Musique]